Hello everybody!
Hello!
Good morning!
It's 6 in the morning for me, but I'm here!
I'm here, guys!
Hello!
I don't want to say a huge thank you to Fate Trigger for sponsoring today's stream.
We are currently broadcast at Gamescom Germany, so hello everyone at Germany, guys!
Hey everybody!
I'm alive and I'll have a lot of coffee inside me right now.
but I'm here hello chats chat say hello to everybody at Germany right now hey guys I haven't been up this early in a long time so today yes I'm awake right now but hello everyone hello yes we're currently at broadcast well I'm not in Germany right now but for all people in germany can see us right now hello everybody uh today we will be playing fake trigger with some of the people that are at the venue right now at gamescom and i'm going to be calling rpr very soon he's actually there as well at at the at the convention so he's playing right there at the arena so we're going to be calling rpr very soon You sound like...
What does that even mean?
I sound like I am in Germany.
Yes, Guten Morgan.
Did I pronounce that correctly?
But hello, everyone.
Oh, my...
Anyway, we're going to do a quick call to RPR very soon.
But yes, today we are playing Fake Trigger.
And they lobby right now.
So as you can see, I'm in the lobby at the moment with some of the play.
I think all these players...
are currently at the arena um right now uh so we're gonna be playing with a lot of these players that are at the arena and we're gonna hope that we don't die die very fast so again huge shout out to big trigger for sponsoring me uh for those who are not at the event not in germany right now and just watching the stream and you want to support the stream you can click on the link that's pinned in the chat and in the description uh below so yes it'll be great help to support the stream and
play at the moment so yeah um all right let me do the call real quick to rpr and see like how see that see the quality of his microphone
calling him
why isn't he picking up hello pick up the call we gotta play hello Hello?
Hello?
Oh, I can hear you.
Yeah, if it's echoing stuff, nothing I can do about it probably.
Yeah.
Am I like just behind you right now in the background?
Look, if I turn to my left, I can see your flank around.
All right.
Let me put you on the screen too on my end.
Well, I can't hear myself though on your end, which is like your mic is actually pretty decent because I can't hear myself.
get at it oh like i'm literally just like blasting in your back and like and i don't hear you but yeah oh like the echo well not echo but like you i am like on the stage so yeah your speakers like right next to me somewhere yeah yeah yeah so it must be like with you right now now it's fine now i have you in my ears all right all right oh i need to fix my set okay i'll fix the setting i'll fix the graphic settings when we're in well whoops accent got out whoops are you gonna like i actually log in marine or what wait i actually left the room don't start it yet i oh my god okay i can't log okay okay wait that's awkward actually press escape i okay give me a sec what's the room password oh oh okay i need to find the room password again okay uh yeah i know yeah i know okay uh yeah i i literally hit the screen okay i'm back hello i'm back okay um i have 200 ping by the way to the server so you're gonna i'm just gonna i'll do exactly what i expected from you i'll do my best i'll do my best
okay i'm ready for real if we lose on stage like it's over for us like okay like everyone can see where we are because my they're broadcasting my stream they all have to just look up from their monitor they know exactly where we are like that's not my fault but like you're you're a professional streamer you're literally oh what do i do hide my entire street screen so like nobody can see where we are all right okay i'm ready we're rotating you should like accidentally like hit like a oh just look at the ground you know like when we're rotating just look at the ground yeah without driving you look at the ground you're like we should go here and i just look at the ground i'll be like yeah i definitely know where we're going all right i'm ready just stare at your guns yeah yeah i'll just stare him i'll stare at my gun for the first like 30 minutes before we rotate.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
I'm playing the support, of course.
I forgot what gun's good, though, in this game.
We're really good gun.
Oh, you're an open mic, by the way.
Am I open mic?
Yeah, you are.
I hear your echo.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
there is that fixed yeah yeah it's fixed now w but then the poor people okay so you gotta talk to people in the game for me because wait what why because i just turned off my mic they can just listen to my stream you tell them on my stream and then they'll just listen they're also at the venue they just listen to my stream wait that means like everybody on the venue can hear our comms.
Yeah.
So, what's the point of talking to our team when they can just listen to the stream?
To be fair, the other streamer can probably hear you talk too, so.
Oh, that is so true.
No, no, because he's a wait, okay, does he, does he like...
He's right next to me.
Oh, okay.
But, like, is he, like, fully fluent in...
Because he's, like, a streamer from Germany, right?
He can understand English, yes.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I was asking, is he fully fluent in English?
He doesn't know what I'm saying.
Okay, I need to turn.
Where are we going, dude?
Wait, am I?
Am I?
No, player 3 is the jump master.
Just take us anywhere.
But not for us to die.
Okay, player 3 that we're going to believe in the player 3.
Yeah, you don't believe in your team.
I just want to go out there.
You don't believe in your team.
I believe in player 3.
So I need adjusted graphic settings.
Listen, I would have also went Slade and...
No, he's changed his mind.
I believe in him.
No, we're back to Slade.
But I believe, and we all have like, you know, one try to die, basically.
Oh, yeah, actually, before we die, we could...
Yeah, exactly.
We can go again.
No, we don't want to die.
Let me... I'm going to turn my graphics to low.
Come on, like...
I was in...
Come on, we're still in the resort?
Alright, here we go.
That should be good.
Whoa.
We're not contested, brother.
Nice.
children oh my god wait what is my ping i'm at 100 oh what's your ping i'm at 180.
okay listen when we played the fate trigger tournament the last time i was on 200 and then i did absolutely fine yeah yeah no yeah that oh i'm okay i'm wait oh they're landing on the car okay i'm so okay there's millions of people watching right now yeah i'm i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying to get in a car right now i'm just i'm trying no you don't understand you don't understand you don't understand it took me four seconds to get in the car you don't know so in the future you can just lay on the car you don't have to be inside of it you'll be fine i'm gonna get out of here i'm moving okay it's fine getting out is one second getting out of the car is fine we're okay we're okay right now so what are the good what are the good guns I like the AK,
not the AK, it was called CKM is good.
And then I like the, okay.
I think there's a gun.
I forgot the name.
It's like Gladiator or something like that.
IG, that's probably the best.
Opening the door.
Okay, it's just a car.
I'm fine with opening doors.
Opening doors is one second.
It was just, oh wait, the Cantius, I remember now.
And then it was the, yeah.
And then it was a Gladiator and what?
Gladiator was the name of the store.
and then uh then select reference from there on uh no what was the other gun what was he it was gladiating what it was yeah there was another gun that was good right zkm the the other the ak what the is oh it's a zkm okay okay who we're shooting oh my god did someone already looking streamstipe those take up a bunch of smogs because we're not even because i'm gonna
okay yeah it's not okay i'm like not it's all six in the morning no i i'm it's you don't understand six in the morning i have not warmed up he's one he's six he's four five six seven you don't understand i'm not locked in right now you don't i also forgot what my sensitivity is for this game whoever sat on this pc has completely changed the controls oh that's not good yeah fell down from a roof i didn't realize there's glass on on top all right oh my god everything's changed i believe him okay why didn't you look at your settings before we started i did but he's i think he goes car you just sat here and he changed every single tab yeah then you could why didn't you re-change it because i thought i'd think okay all right if i if i like crouch here i won't die right because i need to look at my settings too all right hold on are you at home no no every like when um after the last stream like it reset itself because it was a new account so i need to okay wait i need to look at my i'm i
believe in my team don't worry i believe oh my god my cpu is at 100 okay okay you're trolling right now we're literally in the we're in war i said it would be okay i'm fine i'm fine here we go all right You're resing right?
Don't worry.
See?
I'm being resned.
I was down.
Yeah, here.
I healed you.
You're so lucky.
I'm here What the fuck?
It was your own blood, but it was your own blood, but it was.
The fuck?
Okay.
There's the rabbit micro over there.
I mean, I thirsted.
I killed this guy.
You can thirst him.
Where?
I mean, I killed him.
Yeah.
That's the shy.
You killed the shy?
I killed a what?
The shy?
A child?
The shy.
Who's shy?
I don't...
Never mind.
Who's...
Bit forwarded.
Okay, let me...
Okay, I'm gonna...
Let me look at...
I'm at 100% CPU.
I need to figure out how to turn this.
Guys, what do...
How do I fix this?
Is this like a setting stream?
Like, lock and...
I'm at 100% CPU!
I'm trying to fix my shit!
Okay, give me...
I'm actually getting gear by random, like, we're actually getting gear right now.
It's okay.
It's fine.
That's good.
Full-time streamers, professional players, and...
You didn't even look, you didn't even change your settings.
You didn't even change your settings.
I did change my settings, but Cario, like, literally on purpose.
Yeah, and you didn't re-change, you didn't look at it.
You had, like, 10 minutes to fix that.
Get in the car.
Where are, where's the car?
Okay.
Okay, give me a second.
It takes like four seconds for me to get in a car.
Give me a sec.
okay while we're in the car chat guys what else do i change to make it so that my cpu isn't at 100 do i change the anti-aliased thing do i do that or do i like change the dlss quality i'm pretty sure it's presets and you can just put it on low i i did put it on low oh okay there you go i put on extra low all right there you go now it should be okay it was fine like let's go loot we actually have to get purple armor we have to level up our guns we have to get the money yeah i'm like we have to lock in here okay i'm gonna turn me i'll close this chrome tab and then she's in chrome that was sick there like we're so locked in oh wait maybe i'll fix the frames it's okay you're driving i have plenty of time to fix this okay i'll do 100 and i'm driving 44 oh wait i'm done okay there we go oh shit okay i'll go loot too hello get get smokes if you can get any nades are actually really good like like i didn't use nades when we were in the tournament you didn't use nades in tournament no no
wonder we didn't
the invited the competition that that messed us over it's never your fault it's not of course oh my fault oh wait look at the green car wait run them over yeah i would love to but they're not exactly on the road oh that sucks yeah i could go on but we're literally we're not old we gotta chill all right i'll chill
inside oh no you could oh okay wait wait TP here TP here to that player listen to my stream it's TP here okay or I'll use my special revive I'm safe it's just one left okay okay I roll it I've used my all for no reason you're trying to communicate with them by telling them by streaming at me yeah exactly you know that they'll hear me there's a team game voice chat what do you mean they can hear me voice chat why use that when they can listen to my stream i'm getting stream sniped anyway by the entire lobby they might as well listen you're gonna make me crash out on stage what do you mean you can stream snipe they can look they can look up from their monitor and know exactly where we are what the do you mean
it's only like five seconds today it's fine for them i'm just wondering why my cpu is at a hundred percent we should we should probably go yeah we should go to the shopping thing and just buy like weapon marks and stuff oh that's true that's true all right i'm still looking at my settings too you should probably get the weapon mode for for no drop because you can't aim uh it turns the game into overwatch brother so anti-aliasing that's okay maybe i turn off anti-aliasing oh wait this is oh wait there's people just move just people get out of your settings again oh okay okay i got this oh where's my gun you got purple armors dude i have to reload
i feel like my sense you got an h throw them i don't Wait, I do.
Of course you don't.
I did!
I literally threw...
Oh my god, I fucked up my...
I threw a smoke.
Listen, they're all on wall hats, so...
Oh, I'm dead.
Wait, there's people behind us.
Let's be nice.
Um, I'm dead because, uh...
You were like, let's shoot them and I was like, okay.
Listen, he get...
Hello.
I can give up.
I don't know.
But whenever you get up, get in the car, start healing.
We're out of here.
Just stop pressing me.
again i got stopped the rest like several times oh they did they miss i get heal yourself the ability okay yeah yeah yeah let's go player two and we out dude see we did it see it wasn't so hard you're stressing me out it's it's yeah there you go but he wants to fight i'm down i'm down i'm not gonna fight from this house i'm just gonna heal goodbye i'm healing in this car right in front of us yeah we're yeah there is a guy right in front of we got this guy oh they're doing wall hack shit on us I got the wall hack I think they're dead they're all dead okay are you all dead what the fuck yeah they're all dead one team of these there's big backpack here oh pick up maids yay see Look,
I can be in the settings and we still win.
Everything's fine.
Why are we so worried?
Alright, look, see, we're okay.
Look at us.
Look, we killed so many.
Look, see, we're top 30.
Is there anything in the drop?
We're top 10.
Look at us go.
Oh, no.
They all took everything.
This is the upgrade station.
We just do this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got money?
Yeah, I have.
No, I have $20.
I was not looting anything other than guns.
Okay, can someone spare some change?
Yes, I am.
I'm begging on stream.
Alright, guys, all the people at the arena, we are at, we're right here.
we're right here if you guys want to come over and give i need like more i got by 45 if you guys don't want to kill us we're right here and can leave put your money over here in front thank you so much for reminding the whole server right here at this edge right here Everyone should just come to us.
Yeah.
Just donate your loot to us real quick.
You're not mine.
I'm gonna...
I got the backpack.
I got second one.
What did I get?
All right.
Hello.
I am.
It's six in the morning.
I'm usually not awake at the time.
I had to chug coffee before the stream.
What do you usually do?
wake up like like 11 a.m or some shit up to cap all right
my cpu's still at oh okay let me double check okay it's at 86 now okay it's a little better now yay oh hey there's another thing here no one touched this one over yeah it should be open oh yeah definitely nobody touched this all right uh the second oh wait all the things i used to upgrade is gone now because i took i guess i took the gold backpack oh this person is going to use the nail on here oh hey we're top seven look at that we're so good we're winning i'm winning by doing absolutely nothing at all This is great.
He's going to just run me over.
That's good.
Good for him.
What are you going to do for him?
Bad for me.
Good for him.
Well, maybe you should be a better driver.
I don't think this is going to pull up, so I think we should stay under silent.
Alright, for those who want to know where we are, we're right here.
Do you guys want to fight us?
I'm so happy that I'm so happy.
Guys, alright, everyone who's still alive, look up from your screen so you know where we are.
We're right here.
Come to us if you want to fight.
Oh, look, they're fighting down there.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, let's go.
Wait, when they're moving, run them over.
Run them over.
Oh, you're fucking...
You take the car and you run them over.
No, no, I'm not running them over at 200 ping.
Oh, I can't kill them.
I'm 110 on one.
Yeah, 125.
You're kill stealing now.
I hit 125.
There's no way.
Stop kill stealing.
It was actually 50 damage.
I was like, don't be bad, it's just that easy.
I'm being bad.
Then maybe I won't kill still.
One team is dead, but I think there's one more team.
There's a guy right here at the bottom.
I feel like we're going to get, like, ran at.
No, we're going to, there's someone above us.
There's someone above us that ulted us.
Oh, we're getting ulted.
Yep.
We should take a car.
Get in the car and run?
Yeah.
Is there another car that we could steal?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Our other car is almost dead though.
You say there's a guy here, you lied.
Like there's no one here.
Okay, but who ulted behind us?
Oh no, there is.
I literally...
No, I saw a guy like ran there.
I literally saw him.
I saw him like skate down.
Watch my stream.
Rewatch my stream.
I don't have rewind, huh?
Yeah, I got you.
There we go.
Where's his team?
Where's his car?
We need a car.
There's a car right there.
Wait.
His team is over there on red.
Look, look.
On there?
Oh, I see him.
He's running.
10 still person.
175?
He's dead.
Okay, nice.
Alright, let's get the other car before we get shot at.
Let's get this one.
Yeah, yeah.
pretty sure the ult behind us was our own teammate ulting and then probably jolted oh like okay okay i was gonna be like why is there okay is it though how are all of you gold armor and i'm purple i don't know don't be bad i guess i'm going back a little bit there has to be one gold no because there has to be a gold armor if there's a special package here i'm gonna just check it yeah just check it what's gonna happen to us we're getting a shot at it'll be so funny you could like Yeah,
guys, we're right here.
We're getting a jet.
We're getting a jet collector because...
You don't want to shoot us.
You're going to die and I'm going to need it.
I'm going to need it.
Wait, someone dropped something.
Three mores left.
Yeah, top four.
Let's go.
Look at this.
Find a photo of us.
Also, like, I'm Doki Bird 4.
That means someone stole Doki Bird 1 and 3 before I could make this account.
That's two.
No, I was two.
I was two.
But, like, someone made...
through one and four what are my i can't even tell what my frames are oh it has to be good frames because it doesn't feel like i'm dropping this card does not go up though but it's tough wait there's another special package let's get that yeah maybe i get gold here did you yeah that is oh there's a portable teleporter i want that okay get that out of here I want that.
What do I just take here right now?
I'm just gonna park the car here and I'm gonna just look over the hill.
Wait, I hear a car.
Wait, I think someone's gonna try and run us over.
Yeah, behind us, behind us, behind us.
I don't think they're trying to run us over, but they're trying to run to us.
Oh, that was awkward.
Oh, that's awkward.
Out of the car, sir.
Why did he stay in the car?
I think they have teammates though.
No, they definitely do.
They have to.
Wait, I made a shot from this side.
Okay, chill.
That's like the legendary sniper.
Oh.
I'm pretty sure one of them used the legendary sniper over there.
Wait, why don't we just run up to him?
What is he going to do?
Shoot at us?
Yeah, it's just one guy.
I don't think he realized we're going to run up to him.
I cracked him.
Kill him.
He's dead.
Does this hurt me?
Is that full kill?
Yeah, it's a full kill.
Well, actually, I don't know.
No, no, no, it's not full kill.
It's not full kill.
Here.
Now that's full kill.
Now we're full kill.
We should probably like look for more cars.
This is the last team.
Hey, last person.
We're right here.
Come 1v1 us.
You're so confident this person's watching us.
Yes, look up from the monitor.
You're still alive.
to know where we are oh okay i see them see i told you they looked at my stream why how i was going to drive like that they don't even know they literally can't just look up for my monitor and see where we are oh oh okay don't want to be one of us anymore i i don't want to be one anywhere yeah maids right you know maids right i did not sick i have smoke grenades that's not mine though
armor no one on the roof not on the roof got a guy on the roof of 57 six on one of them i'm good luck you want to like what it's fine it's totally fine they don't want but they're probably raising on the roof i'm pretty sure they are why else would they be doing i'm scanning yeah they're about it,
but nice.
Knocked another one from the building.
Okay.
Two down, guys.
If you're watching the stream, two got down.
We're not coming with you, by the way.
I knocked another one.
Okay, cool.
I'll heal you.
I'll wait.
Thanks.
Big.
Um, teammates, you go down.
I'll res.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I could use some help.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I altered.
Okay.
I altered outside.
Thank you so much for your ult.
They're throwing nades and shit.
Where are they?
Now if you had nades you could throw some nades too, though I don't have nades.
I don't have nades.
I ulted outside, but then I think that was a bad idea I just made it myself stay.
Oh shit.
Yeah twice I'm gonna die here.
I'm gonna heal me heal me heal me.
Oh my god.
Okay, chill chill chill.
Don't raise me What if I raise you're right here and you get shot at wouldn't it be funny if I get full killed now It's you gotta win the game alone.
Yeah, we have teammates we have teammates believe in our teammates wait where is our you're the professional streamer oh wait wait how did they die second floor second floor okay okay i'm heading over here it's fine oh my god i'm getting body block i am okay i'm just getting i don't know where they're dead in there wait they're right below they're below someone's one of them is below He ran outside.
He ran outside my door.
Come to me.
Fucking don't know where people are.
Wait, outside.
On me, on me, on me, on me.
He's on me.
He's low, he's low, he's low, he's low.
I hit like, I hit like, I don't know how many, how much.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, see?
I definitely know what I was doing.
You're so stressful.
Oh, my God.
We did it.
You're stressing me out, Kirk.
Hey, I'm not even bottom frag.
Look at me.
I'm not even bottom frag That's not true.
I had more kills than the last the other guy you were in your settings page half the game The fact that I was in settings were half my game and I'm not bottom frag says a lot The fact that I did more damage than two of my teammates well in my settings What the fuck do you mean?
I am!
Why the fuck are you doing my damage when I'm in my settings?
Yes, I am!
Just for the people that are in the venue here because I could...
Because I'm here physically, I think you guys carried.
Doki's not here, so she can just get whatever she wants.
Hey, hey, look, I think they did a great job.
They did a great job, but all I'm saying is that I clearly put up my weight because I did... I was second fragger for some reason.
Wait, is there going to be a new lobby?
Yeah, a new lobby, you're going to get the code.
Don't leak it.
Oh, wait, they already made it.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
And hide your screen.
Okay, can you tell me what the...
Okay, I got it.
Do you have the code?
Okay, so the first number is zero.
Wait, it says the password's not right.
Is that not?
Oh, wait.
Okay, the first number is zero.
Does Doki have the code?
Yeah, I do.
I do.
Do I need to give Doki the code?
No, no, I got it.
I'm in.
Oh, okay, okay.
She's in.
She just typed the wrong code.
Yeah, I just, yeah.
Yeah, I am.
I'm so professional.
Professional streamer.
That's right.
That's me.
Hey, people are having a good time.
What if we don't get carried now?
Okay, let's... Okay, who's the...
Okay, who's the guy?
Who's the highest ranked person in this area in this arena right now?
Wait, I can type it who has played Play trigger Get on our team Dude, we are watching This is a PR nightmare What do you mean?
This is a PR nightmare How I just We want the best possible team Don't we Let the other streamer win one Dude like stop being selfish I am Oh wait they're talking Oh wait they're talking Does not exist alone Ah Oh maybe he's testing his mic Maybe
Someone said Doki's gonna make RBR jump off the stage Yay Oh can someone really film there's literally nothing that would happen to me yeah it's like ground level it's like it's it's not even it's not even a meter high i mean if you land on your head and something will happen unless there's like nothing in there yeah i'll just go land on my head thanks way trigger for sponsoring us we really appreciate it
regretting this moment.
We're having a great time.
I am having a great time.
Because you won a game.
Let's see who loses.
I had a great time even before we won the game.
Because we are- Can you at least stop flaming our randoms?
Because you're not in the venue with them, I am.
I didn't even flame them.
I just said do better.
I said do better.
That's not flaming.
I'm like encouraged them to get better at the game.
So how about, let's go there.
Okay.
The player T is flying here.
Okay, I definitely need a like...
Okay, we're going straight down.
Lower my...
I didn't even want to go.
I didn't even want to go agriculture.
I wanted to go here.
Okay, I'm lowering my sense.
I'm still trying to figure out what my sense is for this game.
Because I forgot what...
No, I'm literally...
I'm not in settings anymore.
I was like, oh my god, let me lower my sense just a little bit.
You know, people at the venue are watching you here in half the game, the last game, they're watching you being in your settings.
Okay, yeah, and we won.
And we won.
And I did more damage than our other teammates.
So, like, how about that?
I did not warm up, too.
Like, I still did, like, top second fragger.
Okay.
Let's go.
Are we contested?
I don't know.
Hold on.
Wait, this guy's emoting.
Let's go.
See, now I know I'm not the fuck-around person here.
Wait, can I say...
Can I swear?
I did what you're asking me I mean like I could stop like I could just stop yeah okay please swear wait see put the f-bomb in there wait is the Jackson good I forgot I'm not gonna swear just in case you should use it why it's not fair you gotta be a team how are we not a team if you don't like contribute.
If you get fine, I don't want to get fine.
I'm not going to get fine, am I?
I don't know.
Wait, I mean, the devs are literally right there.
Ask him right now.
Ask the devs right now.
Devs are off the stage.
I'm not going to go...
No, just ask the devs.
Am I...
Wait, they can listen to the stream.
Devs, am I okay?
Am I...
Devs, can she swear she can't stop herself.
I can't stop myself.
I've done it before!
I just need a no!
Okay, so...
Okay, we're good.
I'm okay.
Everything will be fine.
Wait, what are we doing anyway?
We're looting!
Oh.
I need...
I need a canteus.
I just haven't found a canteus yet.
Yeah, I found a canteus.
Yay!
I asked and I received.
I'm going to try out a shotgun with me.
Okay, I'm shooting my gun, but there's nobody.
I just want to test my sense.
Okay, I'm just testing my sense.
I lowered it a little.
It was so fast earlier, so I lowered it.
I think the shotgun's really good.
I mean, it's getting close range.
It's like, uh, just a two pump.
Oh, I hear people shooting, yeah.
Oh, there must be, like, two people here.
Let's get rid of them.
I believe.
here oh you already killed us no yeah we're getting carried again yay i have 200 ping so i deserve to get carried be fair it doesn't feel like i have 200 ping though the register the shot register is pretty good yeah i'll put into the bigger stuff okay where are they anyway there's nobody here we killed one oh there I'd say that and then I like with three shots.
That's...
They had to be like...
There's no way that was totally on his body.
I was blaming Ping for that.
Just killed him.
I saw them.
Why are they running in the open?
Poor guy.
I mean, they get around too anyway.
Yeah, they get a res.
Don't worry, sir.
You can come back.
Don't worry, if you died from us, don't worry, you'll come back.
Check this out.
I want to get back to the first three zones or something.
Three zones.
And then it's all bullying randoms.
They're not randoms.
They're real people.
Yeah, we want to win.
Hello.
We were paid to win and not paid to lose.
Yeah, redeem ourselves from the tournament.
I'll take it.
I think that's how it works, but...
This is a paid-a-win lobby.
You guys are good stuff here.
You guys just gave me the knob paid-a-win?
No, it's not.
Guys, I'm just saying that we're sponsored a win.
Oh, a lot of purple armor.
Look at this.
Oh, shit.
It's not paid-a-win, guys.
But since we're gamers, we're skilled to win.
What else?
Take the purple armor.
the purple oh there it is i think that there's a purple backpack i was trying to get on the room this building is crazy we should have just landed here all right we got some oh yeah there's a purple magnet wait didn't someone else land here oh wait there's a three x go i need that actually i have a simple joys what does that mean why is my gun like has a oh we're actually i'm i'm fine right now my loot's fine
I'm okay money money let's uh we should probably hit up one of these things we enhance our drones smart but our player two is on the white armor there's literally there's blue armor at the bottoms sir or ma'am there's come over here listen to my stream player two listen to my stream and look at me and head over to me listen they already picked they already picked it up okay never don't you don't have to listen to my stream anymore it's okay go back to your monitor go back
i can't i just did i just did i just did i yeah Turn on your PR mode.
You did not turn on your PR mode.
I haven't swore a single time.
You said worse stuff without having to swear.
Huh?
You've said worse things without having to swear.
Alright, I am right behind you.
I'm right behind you.
I can't repeat it because I'm not a PR nightmare.
i'm just like i'm just like i'm just a brand risk no no no we're a brand risk together that that might be true that actually might wait we need a car why are you doing here i'm looking for one there's one right here wait here's shots you hear that behind us
I don't know, player three is shooting somewhere.
Is he fine?
It'll be fine, right?
It's fine.
He can get res if he...
Yeah, he can get res if he dies.
We got money?
Like, we gotta do enhance.
No, I have $10.
How?
Because, like, everybody took all the money.
Like, I don't fucking know.
Sorry, I don't freaking know.
Yeah, you can really stop your thing.
It's your fault.
I'm gonna wait until someone gives me money.
to give me like 45 dollars so now we're extorting him for money no i said please give me 45 dollars did you say please please give me 45 i'll give you money let me just let me just enhance me okay oh he was getting shot by the way he put out a shield where was he getting shot money money money yeah he was getting shot behind us yeah from where we came from because we killed only three from the team so yeah or like a new team or maybe they respawned or came back yeah I mean it was goaded loot I'm not seeing that I don't see anybody I just heard shots
oh oh I'm waiting.
I was gonna push.
Just run them over.
Just get a car and run them over.
Yeah, do that.
Oh, like, player two and three, run them over.
It'll be so funny.
Alright, I'll just drive with our guy.
Oh, we're running?
No, run them over.
Drive them over.
Don't be...
Don't be weak.
Drive them over.
Don't be what?
Don't be... Don't be...
Don't be weak.
Go run them over.
Drive.
Just drive.
Oh, like, yeah, see, it's that easy.
Oh, wait, I should have executed.
I get the perk.
Oh, wait, there's a guy.
Here, he's dead.
Tony more.
No, no, no, no, don't run him over.
Why not?
See what you did, Duffy?
I didn't run him!
If I execute him, you get wall-locked on all of them.
What did you say?
I didn't do anything.
What did I do?
That's why he, like, full killed, I'm pretty sure.
She was both killed.
I know.
All right.
We gotta go observatives, you know.
Where do we go now?
Are we letting player two drive?
Well, I mean, I can't kick him off the car, so yeah.
Player two, can you leave your car for a bit in Helen?
It's fine.
Player two can drive.
Let's see.
I believe in you, player two.
RPR did not believe in you.
I always believed in you.
But RPR messaged me on...
Messaged me on Discord and was like, we shouldn't let Player 2 drive.
And I was like, that's messed up.
Okay.
I trust you, Player 2.
We're getting shot from behind.
Run them over.
You got this Player 2.
Just run them over.
Okay, it's okay.
Don't run them over.
Run them over.
Run them.
He's still alive.
Oh, wait.
He's dead.
I'm gonna
That's fine We can find another player This is what the pain feels like We can run over the next guy And then you can do your thing Okay, let's go Let's go observatory Okay Red thing Here, here Get over here Layer 2 Wait, wait, there's another guy Run him over Run him over Run him over I hate you I hate you I hate you Like you're actually Like,
just let me scan.
It's not my fault.
You know, I'm a player three now, dude.
Yeah, but player two is going to be.
And you guys can go around all the people over there.
I believe in you, player two.
You got this.
I like your style.
Where were we?
I heard gun.
Why were you shooting?
Yeah, no, someone was shooting.
It was crazy.
Yeah.
Oh, don't, oh, we don't have gas.
We don't have gas.
We got a swap.
Oh, that's so fortunate.
Yeah.
It's time to swap guns.
All right, player two, player.
Oh, okay.
Player two left.
I don't think they know.
Oh, let's go to airdrop.
I don't think they know that their cars ran out of gas.
Here you go, player two.
We should probably hunt airdrop to get a legend.
That's true.
I'm driving now and 200 ping.
Do you think we'll be okay?
I think you wouldn't be okay if you were okay.
Oh yeah, that's true.
I remember what happened.
When I...
I already did this.
There you did?
No.
See, the harmonizer capture started.
Stupid.
Oh, you can read what's the same.
Okay.
I'm going to go up the stairs, man.
Actually...
You gotta stand in circles so we can...
get it done for us.
Well, why can't our randoms do it?
Sorry, not randoms.
Our lovely players are with us.
Okay, players, players two and three, stand here.
I want to loot.
I want to loot now.
They say, oh, wait, it's fully looted up top.
I don't think there's much loot above us.
Yeah, there is.
Yeah, it's looted.
No, but they, sometimes it has good loot at the top.
I remember.
I'm here now.
Looks like someone got you from the You'll need it.
Is it a car?
Is it?
I hear a car.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going ahead up because I don't want them to run at me.
Oh my god, I know.
Come on, I think.
Yeah, I did.
Are you guys doing it?
I don't see anybody.
No.
I'm like a little lost right now on the second floor.
Don't worry, I'm here to help.
I did it.
I did it, guys.
Well, guys.
I was there.
I got lost.
I actually...
Oh, nice.
I actually sort of got lost in the room area.
Oh, they are corrosive.
Gladiator.
Oh, corrosive Gladiator.
Wait, that's good.
I don't even get to use my shotgun.
I kill everyone in that range.
Okay.
Now we go back here.
We gotta stand back here again.
Alright guys, we gotta do this thing again.
How do you emote?
Um, I don't remember.
How do we emote?
The other guy was dancing in front of me.
Oh wait, is that another player?
Well, let's...
Let's go.
From there.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh my god, in a car!
We're up!
Holy shit!
I!
Wait!
There's two people on the street!
Oh my god, that guy run over?
We killed two.
What happened?
Come to me, come to me, come to me, go to me!
I don't know what happened to me.
I don't know what happened to you.
I literally exploded.
You got run over or no, the car blew up and you took a lot of damage.
Oh, okay.
That makes more sense.
Um, I'm with you.
This is so risky.
He's helping from up top.
Our team got full kill, but we can retrieve.
Okay.
You full heal yourself and then get an idea.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm here.
I think second floor is probably too strong.
I am fully healing myself.
I got him on scan, I think.
Oh my God.
I got exploded.
Got one?
Okay.
I'm heading to the roof.
right now where are they in the smoke in the smoke one's not in the smoke i'm like randomly shooting it i'm i'm burning him this month i just threw like a million oh okay i got hit by something i got sniped by something i got sniped by something i don't know where i'm healing i'm healing i don't know where i got sniped oh okay deep left deep left oh it's it's yeah yeah i killed the sniper I have thirsty one just in case we have to go to the zone I'm gonna go pick her up pick that I made up I killed all I killed all I'm extracting you're all dead all dead you can just res or there I don't think this zone hurts I mean share how do I res again oh T just put it down yeah yeah I put it down I'm just gonna head to the zone though okay so it basically exploded in mean that's why basically what happens here the car here with a car and then i blew up the car oh so you blew up the car and i died oh okay that makes sense because i literally was like wait no you almost killed yourself too because
you almost died from that you actually almost that's actually that's actually like the most stupid thing you've ever done that's no that's the most stupid thing you've ever done okay and i like i like how you left our teammates and here taxing them i just want to make sure that i'm just scouting out for us i'm literally scouting that's what he's gonna die player two four four is healed four is healed you could also you know heal them your ability yeah i can right now because you're too far okay now i can see there you go i don't say never do anything get me good zone okay that's actually pretty far i had to secure the zone for us guys i was a team player
i don't think it was almost out of fuels my car has lots there's another car behind you guys that you can swap your car has a lot of fuel but you're the one driving it so um you can drive this car whenever you want i got a new one i got a new one wait wait there's a fight in front of us gosh i don't know if i should be here this way this way i hear shots this way oh my gosh i'm not okay We should go get high ground before we do anything.
Wait, there's people shooting in front of me.
They're below the ridge.
Oh, wait, actually, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Let them die in zone.
I'm just going to kill a little bit.
All right, I'm just going to...
I'm driving the zone.
Don't worry, I'll secure the zone, guys.
But there's people who are shooting in front of me.
I have $730, I think.
Money.
I have $375.
securing zone zone secure you're not even in zone what are you securing you're not even in the zone zone secure I'm securing outside the zone I'm scouting I'm scouting there you go I'm pretty sure he just run someone over player three oh nice good for him uh we're dead center okay i don't like being in the center i see people shooting from really far away i'm gonna get out of car now oh they're on the enhancing station that's that's what it's called for sure i don't see them right now they're on the roof on the roof yeah okay i'll just scan for you soon okay it's just one guy wait it's one guy yeah he's still dead Okay,
he's definitely dead But he has teammates.
Where is his teammates?
They had teammates Now I wish I had a sniper He said I'll shot him.
Are we gonna live in the hand station now?
Yeah, this is our time Okay, one more up there three.
I got you There's a guy He's in the middle of the road red guy.
That guy is crazy That guy is Z for doing that.
Oh, we won.
Oh, that's the last guy.
Wait, what happened to everybody?
Okay, this time I didn't do a lot of damage.
I was actually fucking around.
You actually got out damage by everyone.
I got, yeah, I was messing around.
What did you do this whole game?
I healed.
Settings again?
Oh, it says the guy that like exploded a car in our faces.
And killed 14 people.
Like, hello?
And including your teammates, you killed your teammates.
I sacrificed you.
You know what, player three, sure, I'll be your friend, player three.
Another player three, sure.
Friend, sure, let's do it.
I'll friend all these players.
Carrying doki was so hard.
Can we make her play harder and then can I just go a little bit?
I was I felt we were carried by our random I played this gang character because I just think she's very useful just knowing enemy's position in Balor Rale is always going to be the most useful thing and it just works well with any combination so you're doing like PR PR's interview right now very useful also for the rocks I guess what's that again very good for securing the rocks wise Overall,
I think...
You think what?
You think you can think?
Well, he muted himself.
He doesn't want me to hear anymore.
That's messed up.
Why mute yourself?
Let the people know.
Oh, we're just waiting for...
We're just waiting for RPR right now.
I was getting asked how...
So basically what asked me is, how do you keep carrying Godoki so hard?
It's insane.
Sure, sure, buddy.
Playing two declined my friend request?
Who are you?
No, someone, I sent friend request to a randoms and they denied my friend request.
The person that was playing with us.
Maybe they're not allowed to accept friends because it's like not their accounts.
It's messed up.
You don't want to be friends with me?
I don't want to be friends with you either.
They basically, like the interview asked me, Oh my god, Doc, he's so, so bad.
Like, how do you keep, like, just, like, winning with her in the same team?
It's like, listen, sometimes you've got to lock in and just carry the flanker, you know, and that's what I do.
I carry the flanker.
Okay, fun.
Fun.
I'll stop playing support.
Now you don't have any heals.
No, no, no, that character is really good.
No, I'm not going to play her anymore.
No, because I'm so bad.
I'm not playing her anymore.
Maybe she just wasn't my character.
But mature.
I'll play the healer, girl.
What if I play the healer girl and I still care?
No.
No, no, no.
Nobody plays her.
No one is allowed to play.
No one is allowed.
Yes, exactly.
No one is allowed to play her now.
She is probably the best character in the game, but I don't know.
No, no.
I'll play her so nobody can get healed.
Except for our randoms.
I'll heal our randoms.
Just not RPR.
So you're going to play her and then you're not...
Yeah, I'm gonna play her and heal my teammates except for RPR exception.
Alright, cool, cool.
Yeah, yeah, use your- I don't get heals anymore.
Yes, you don't- you've lost your healing privileges.
You healed me once in two games.
Never flayed the support or they'll never heal you.
I think I'll lose you.
I raised you twice.
I raised you.
Yeah, because one of them you killed me with.
A car.
You literally killed me with a car.
Okay, but you were sacrificed for the greater good.
What greater good?
I got six kills from that.
What do you mean?
There's four people.
My KD.
There's four people in one team.
Where does the five and six come from?
No, I killed the first four, and then there's two from the other team that came.
I don't know about that.
I mean, I don't know.
I feel like our teammates who are very good teammates.
also contributed to those kills not everything's just about you rpr sometimes we have teammates that help out along the ride check my water check my water i don't need a bot review to know what actually happened you did 231 damage last game let's stop yapping and start locking in yeah because i was mostly running around and healing people like a good teammate like a good support i want my chat some of my chats it says the womb that trashed off her first teammates no i didn't shocked him.
I gave them constructive criticism.
It was constructive criticism.
A player 3 is our jump master.
It's always player 3.
Have you noticed?
Yeah, I do.
I trust my player 3s.
Player 3s have been the good players.
They've been treating us well.
We have all agreed to jump here.
Let's go.
Okay.
Well, I'm waiting for the jump master to jump.
He's gonna go, right?
He's not.
Oh, there he is.
He's just trying to jump.
to get closer why are you judging him i know you know some people why are you judging him he was oh no the bottom he was just trying to figure it out he's learning the game my gosh i appear so mean the new players okay i'm learning here yeah let player three cook
all right i am army wait what no it start this for dc for a little bit uh someone someone said you you were lost in the building for three minutes oh my god there's someone in my building killed them i don't have a gun they took the gun in front of me because i'm too high to bang my auto loot didn't take the gun oh my god here take this okay i got it there was a guy in front of me but i don't know where he is now yeah i'll figure it out Let's see.
Are you sure it was not a teammate?
Wait, was it my teammate?
No, it was not.
Oh, wait, it's my teammate.
Oh, my gosh.
It's player three.
The name tag did not show up.
That scared the shit out of me.
There is a guy there.
Oh, there is?
There is a guy.
Oh, JK.
Yeah, it is him.
Oh, my God.
You gaslit me in this building in front of me.
You gaslit me.
I'm throwing.
Oh, it's okay.
We can respawn.
It's fine.
We're not throwing.
We'll respawn.
There's a guy upstairs, by the way.
I know.
I knocked him.
There's a second guy up.
Wait, behind me, behind me, behind me, behind me.
I need help.
Tell I've healed yourself.
I'm trying.
I did.
Oh, the guy's prone up here.
I have to heal.
I can't believe he prone on me.
I'm healing.
Do you kill him?
Yeah, I killed him.
There's another guy.
Oh, shit.
Shit, I'm getting shot at.
Against knife?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm trying to figure out where he is.
I don't know.
Righty.
In this building.
I killed the other one.
There's only one more guy left.
No, but that's more to the four people then, right?
Well, the other one, the other one, he didn't full die.
That's the thing.
Yeah, see?
Oh, now you full died.
Okay.
I think he full died because he just, like...
gave up to respy yeah i gotta loot something i knew i knew there was a guy here on me was jackson a good gun i don't remember which one the jackson i'll describe it it's called smg the jackson smg oh yeah i think ostriches are good but i don't like most fights have been happening like long to mid range so i haven't even been able to shoot them that's true like gladiator and like a DMR.
Yeah, I have my canteus ready.
Yeah, so then just get a gladiator probably or like an AK or ZK.
Alright.
Oh, hey, blow armor.
Look at that.
Alright, for the one for the people that like rushed us, like rushed us.
We're right here.
Come at us again.
Okay.
Can we loot for three seconds?
We are at what is it called?
The Sladen India guys who are still who are still alive that's where we are come at us well it will take you all down it makes it more fun when they know where we are rvr yeah yeah it makes it more fun it's the it's the thrill just so you can do 200 damage again well i know i did more i know i have more than 200 damage right now wait one full squad got uh okay let's see i'm gonna go to this area surely i'd be okay right i want to scope for my sniper like three times four times many times wow i'm gonna go up here any purple stuff anywhere i feel like this arena would have a lot of things but it doesn't i don't know why this has nothing
i'm pretty sure that things loaded will look where no that not the not the thing i was at this area had nothing had jack aren't you are you on a roof no i went downstairs because there was nothing so i was like maybe it's on the roof but there's nothing in the roof either i thought this place was not real yeah i think we're i think you're thinking about the wrong things i'm still trying to find like a better oh there's another canteus here you need one no i'm running the the bolts right from there see oh i've I found purple in this.
Never mind.
I got a purple.
Where's the...
Where can we go, Luke?
I want a car.
We all want a car.
Take our car.
No move.
Okay.
There's so many panties.
Holy shit.
Oh, I found a car next to me.
Never mind.
That's not...
I thought it was a car.
No other car is here.
Except for the one you're in.
Yeah, I wish you could drive around and get a new car.
Yeah.
All right, I'm ready There three get in I like how you could literally use the in-game voice and you choose not to I think you can listen on the stream I don't need to also I don't know they can't hear you.
We're lucky because of their headset.
They can't hear you There's no way There's no you can literally hear me.
I'm no he was breaking the window Well, why is he why did he think?
Oh, was he?
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, there is people in this.
Oh.
The cars.
Well, they had two cars.
Oh, they got two cars.
Yeah.
Are we gonna...
I mean, are we gonna get off the car or...
Or we won't get an angle or do you want to just fight in the open and die?
I mean, we could have had high ground.
We could run them over.
Get off the car.
You can drive and run over.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna do it.
Are you dead?
Where are they?
I don't know where the last team is.
Yeah, where's the last guy?
I need their stuff though.
Wait, where did I run them over?
Wait, where's their stuff?
So three are dead and one is running?
Whoa.
Yeah, who's through that?
He's dead.
dead that's right you don't get to throw only knock this might be a different team oh or they already maybe they respawn i think they respawn because we thirsted too remember
and they sell they're still respawn available all right let's get in the car oh wait it's gladiator i needed that actually gladiator yeah oh they took the scope they brought us like two cars probably Okay, I need that 3x.
Wait, where did the 3x go?
What?
I think, uh, did she take it?
Yeah, somebody just took the 3x in front of me.
It's not fair.
Oh, airdrop.
We should head there.
Wait, didn't we have, like, three cars?
Now we have one?
Where did our...
We have two.
Oh, wait, I want to upgrade.
I want to upgrade.
Do you have money?
I'm 95.
Here, I'll give you some money.
No, I have...
I have 90.
I don't have money.
Just level up your blue armor.
No, my purple.
I have a... I was the only one with purple.
Oh, wait.
We actually need to like hunt some women.
We actually...
Oh, this is 100.
Okay.
Yeah, that was the only purple thing I have.
Oh wait, the arrows are here.
Let's go for these arrows right here.
Nice.
Hello.
See, we're in the car together.
Is that nice?
Yeah, do you know how to shoot out of a car?
Yeah, I just shoot at it.
I just go, pop, pop.
That's how you do it.
I just go, pop, pop, and then we'll fly.
Guys, there's no mainstream on GameStop chat.
It's me, though, can the helicopter stream.
Yeah, it's us.
We are the mainstream.
Wait, there's no shooting.
Technically, you're on the big screen, so...
Yeah, I am the main stream.
Check me out at Doki Bird on YouTube.
Guys, check me out.
I'm at YouTube at Doki Bird.
Pop pop.
Alright, here you go.
I'm gonna pop pop some people.
What do you mean?
I'm not real, actually.
I'm actually an anime girl.
We're not real.
I can disappear.
So you say anime goes out of the world.
kill those guys not yet but i think no yo yeah see they're i mean they're i don't i mean you ping that so they're heading there oh you're talking about anime girls i'm talking about killing those guys in the game oh okay already moved on for that no i said that you ping that so they don't know where to they are just going to where you ping oh there's an smg oh there's a portable teleporter i like that i think that all right wait wait wait you dropped a backpack i need that actually yeah wait i think okay never mind my teammate took the other purple backpack i never yeah let's go they actually want to fight fair they have like 20 pain we're out of gas oh my god what's up guys do they have gas on their car they got half we had to find another car mission is to find another car guys direction please or because this car is people and take their cars,
you know?
Okay, but we still have to find people.
There's still behind us?
Our team, our players are lost.
We are still...
Maybe they know where they're going.
Maybe they're just trying to find another car.
All right, mission is to...
Oh, there's another car, right?
Yeah, yeah, get that car.
Get that car.
All right, let's just... We'll run over there.
Yay!
I see shots.
I see that.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
This car's crazy with it.
Oh, run them over!
Run them over!
With this thing?
Yeah!
Run them over!
They're right there!
Oh my god, they're so red- Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Maybe don't.
Maybe don't- Maybe don't!
I am!
This thing is not very controllable.
I think I'm gonna get run over soon.
Heal me?
I can't!
You're so far!
There's a car behind you!
There's a car behind us!
There's a new team!
Okay, I'm gonna use my res thing and then you TP to my res if you need to.
Okay, one team should be dead, but there's more people on me.
I- Yeah, I'm gonna go down.
I have the res thing, you can use that.
I'm not gonna- Yeah, you get TP to me.
Hold on, I'm location reveal, I might die.
14 seconds, 14 seconds.
Oh my gosh, 14 seconds.
Okay.
I'm here, I'm here.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna head high ground a little.
We lost our other car, though.
Not so many people.
I don't know who's who anymore.
Yeah, we need to get our other car because there's a lot of people coming over.
A new team from there?
I don't feel very safe here in the open.
I'm taking that car in front of us.
Unless that was the car we ditched.
I got the car.
No, that's nice.
Oh, up the hill, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You hear me?
I'm driving a car, but okay.
Which way?
Okay, this way?
Okay, go get in the car.
Get in the car.
Be honest.
Not there.
That's the other team.
That is behind us.
Okay.
Like in front, like a red pink.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Now I know.
Oh, wait.
Where are they?
I want this one.
Oh, got him.
One team dead.
Oh, our guys.
Our guy's on.
Yeah, yeah.
We can't res.
He's getting shot at.
Yeah, that's something.
I literally can't res out.
I killed them.
Okay, they're dead.
They're dead.
Okay, okay.
Ours.
That's full kill, I think.
Okay, that... I am.
I should be fine.
What a mess.
We live though.
We're alive.
So we got sandwiched by one guy, so it was a whole different team.
All right, I'm gonna go grab my car.
I need a new car.
This car is... I don't know, but we're alive.
that i need yeah i need a 3x there's another one here oh nice okay i'm gonna grab that oh my god get me out of this car okay i'm fine okay i'll drive the car
all right we're good hello this car almost has no more gas though so we gotta swap cars soon as long as you don't use like the special thing um i don't know about that yeah if you use shift like this forward thing the gas gets depleted a lot higher a lot of faster also we do have this oh this this this car has no tires dude just use this one
okay all right you guys can drive in a car with no tires oh my god they're they're tease what are you doing that's no more gas oh yeah it is you're gonna flame the randoms again no i'm just saying that we're running out of gas i'm leaving this car i'm taking this car wait there's a guy in the house it's he's in the house i'm scanning i see him he's on the it's on the city it's one guy 105 he's dead he can literally i 105 him he's right here he has to heal how do you get up here i don't know he's at the car there's i'm gonna I believe I would watch yeah he didn't he did it only knocked though that means I mean I don't know I don't know what this is your fault how is that my fault you're the one that because you literally finished every single person I did not finish every single person you're coping you're gaslighting that's not wait why is there a bike there's a bike here Yeah,
check.
Somebody spawned here.
Wait, I wanted those tickets.
Where do we go?
Weeeee.
I forgot I don't like turning on this car.
Where do we go?
This car, when you use the shift ability, like the super speed, you can't turn.
Yeah, I know.
It's...
Oh, hey, there's a package.
Oh my god, I can't turn.
Never mind.
I use the shift ability.
self-res we'll take one okay oh it's self-rescue kit and an ultimate accelerator accelerator I'll take that yum yum okay hey our guy left me I froze all right how many people I see one but they definitely have two okay maybe I'm Oh, he ulted.
He's like below that.
Oh, he's dead.
Why am I finishing?
Dude, I'm actually stupid.
Look, I might be.
Wait, that car almost ran us over, man.
Wait, there's a...
Oh, down the road.
I didn't finish him.
You want to scan him.
He's right there.
Don't finish him, guys.
Don't finish him.
already scan already scan oh you're gonna scan them this guy this guy this guy has three teammates the other guy only probably has oh oh he's dead player three is finding something this guy did you run him over no okay yes
maybe can you bring the car here so one of our teammates can get in okay are they both just gonna be on my roof vibes all right We got too big vibe.
We can't get across this.
Look, we got ran over in the tournament, so I'm getting my fix right now.
Okay, there is...
Oh my god, there's a lot of teams still alive.
Are you...
Oh, there's a sniper!
There's a sniper over there!
There's a sniper over there.
Yeah, just don't buy it.
Just don't let it down.
He's shooting at me, guys.
and i can't drive i think it's i think it's zero do we go over there we got there's a guy right here oh my god he's shooting my car that's messed up he's chasing after you i hit him one thing legendary i'm gonna try okay okay that that's not how that ability works hey guys i'm gonna drive he's alone in there by the way oh this guy okay i'll drive up i knocked the guy far there's a In this,
like, dome?
How do I get up with my car?
Oh, look what he's like.
He's like.
You use your shift ability on the, on the, like.
Yeah, I can't get up, though.
Oh, here it is.
Can my, you know what?
Wait, he's chasing you?
Why?
He wants to kill you.
I can't hit him, so you might die.
I actually can't hit him.
You might die.
Give me a sec.
I can do that.
You actually might die.
I know I'm fine.
My car is so fine.
Did you run him over?
No, not.
Oh my god, it's two people.
No, there's two people I wanted.
Yeah, multiple people.
There's two people.
I'm fucking driving down.
I'm just...
That's okay.
I could go back up.
I can go back up.
It's okay.
If you press shift on this little like geyser thing, you can actually...
With my car?
What?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
It's like a glider.
Okay, I'm trolling.
Okay, I'm not trolling.
I can't wait.
Are you alive?
I killed him.
I gave up.
I can't run them over.
It was too hard.
But there's one more or something.
Maybe he has Sopras.
Oh, it's over there.
Look at him running.
She's got the beam!
She's got...
Wait, there's more?
Yeah, is there more?
I can't think.
Oh, I do apologize.
No, I think he had self-ris.
Yeah, he had self-ris.
That's a bug.
I thought it was on the phone.
We're gonna shot from behind us.
Look how far.
Look how far he's shooting.
Where?
He's shot a late...
Oh, that's like the charge thingy.
Oh, he's right here.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know what the lead time is for this.
Wait, I'm going to grab this other.
Yeah, my other car is in fire, so I don't trust, like, myself driving over there.
86.
All the other cars are out of range.
Wait, our teammates just left us, bro.
Pick us up.
Yeah, pick us up.
My car is on fire.
Wait, there's another car over there.
Oh no, that's our teammate's car.
I'll drive that car onto them.
Give me a sec.
I'm driving that car.
Someone's driving, right?
I don't know.
I want to take that car and drive him over.
Oh no, that car's on fire.
Never mind, our teammate's car is on fire.
It's not a good idea to pick that car up.
Oh yeah, I got someone's can.
Oh they're in this building.
Oh my god, okay.
No!
Right there.
Poor guy, dude.
You stabbed someone here, yeah, I know.
That's why I'm like trying to figure out where he is.
I don't see anyone.
Try to blow it, hiding.
Oh, I see him, I see him.
An Octa is falling.
That's full team, so it's the only team he's right in front of us.
Yeah, it is.
I got one, I got one.
Just made, if you have nades, sure you pick up nades.
I thirst him, I thirst him, I thirst him, I thirst him.
I mean...
I'm gonna scan in a second okay I got two up two on the discord floor I'm coming over you're like in the back room I'm gonna smoke everything inside wait for my scan and just kill them okay I'll wait.
Our guy is not waiting, but I'll wait.
You scared?
He's trying to flashbang me?
Did you scared?
I'm waiting for this guy.
Not yet, not yet.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I got one.
I got one cracked.
I got one cracked in the back room.
I got two.
Last guy.
I'm healing you.
I was like, I did.
Zero to reporting.
All hostiles eliminated.
Oh, we did.
We did it.
See?
Our team.
work look at that i did stuff this time yeah let's see how much stuff you did yay you got our damage but player two that's fine i lived though i support actually it's fine yeah it's fine i'm a support and i and they ran in and died i lived i lived there solid good job yeah if you want to join the next poppy make sure you don't lick the code again didn't leak anything how did i leak the code and then maybe i'll make it i'm gonna i'm gonna friend people until somebody accepts my friend requests okay let me let me hide this all right okay the first number is zero can you okay they're not gonna figure out the code it's like it's okay i'm not saying how many numbers there are but it's like it's like a lot of numbers did i just it you leaked the code i turn it on though yeah yeah if oh if i leaked it it's so cute instantly leaks the code yeah oh yeah if i leak it see you guys i'm not the problem i don't I told her that she said Yeah,
so she said no more heals for me No, I don't get healed yet That's a lie!
I healed him!
That is a goddamn lie!
This is fake news!
But that's what you said you said no more Heal for me!
I said it!
But it was a joke.
You didn't hear the slash JK You didn't- Slash- slash S?
I said slash JK.
Completely, but okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Completely leaked the thing.
Yeah, look at that.
You know what happened?
And I'm gonna- I'm gonna- I'm going to call a technical timeout.
They declined my friend requested.
They declined my friend request.
Double-click technical timeout.
My mouse double-click on the, on the, on the, when I hit my screen, double-click, it showed the, it showed the hide screen, and then unshowed it.
It's, it's okay.
Technical timeout, not my fault.
It's okay.
I think they didn't have time for a sniper to join.
Not my fault.
Kind of my fault.
Player 2 hates me.
I'm going to friend this player until they become my friend.
Can you stop Harassing everyone in the lobby?
Be my friend.
And player 3, 2.
Oh, player 3 became my friend!
Player 3!
Why player 2 hates me?
How do you keep...
How do you add people from the lobby?
Why can't they be my friend?
Well, do you click manage friend?
Wait, is the Dialocord, the other streamer?
I'm gonna friend them.
Yeah.
They're my friend now.
Accept my friend, will you please?
How do you add people?
You click on their picture and then you just add them.
You click on their profile picture.
Oh, so some of these people already added fun.
Yeah, you're my friend.
I'm adding.
I'm adding player.
Player two always declines my friend request.
I don't understand.
I don't think they like you.
I'm a report player two.
If you don't be my friend, I'll report you.
Complain to the devs.
Devs!
Force them to be my friend!
Where are you?
Or there's gonna be problems.
Yeah, add me or there'll be problems.
Recon.
Recon's wrong.
I like her.
Player 3, like, is friends with me, but player 2 doesn't want to be my friend.
You do realize it's a different person every single time, right?
Yeah, every single time, they decline my friend request.
Maybe maybe like they're like they're just getting unlucky, like getting haters.
I don't understand.
Why be on my team?
Because they want to win, I guess.
I guess they want to be on your team.
They're on my friend's list, though.
No, there's no way.
I play 2 is definitely not on your friend's list.
No, they're not.
Send me a screenshot right now.
I can't.
right now player two being your friend leave this lobby so i can i need proof oh player three is the jump master if i win this lobby you can't win that's not true that's not true i won't shoot anyone this game and i'll see you oh so you're not gonna play the game that you're sponsored to
that's messed up buddy I love this one.
How are people already dead?
We just spawned.
Whoa.
Wait, yeah, how are they dead?
Wait, who killed them?
Where are you guys?
Where are you landing to?
RPR.
You want to land in containers over there?
I'm dropping.
On top of the containers is a ton of good loot.
Okay.
I believe you.
I don't think there's anybody that uh only anybody landed here i'm not sure i'm not actually looking yeah i think so too hello player three i'm gonna steal your loot sick it's okay player three is my friend so they're okay with that you have a player two on the internet yeah player two fuck you i mean
i mean i mean i can i let's let's be friends this one should have been great thank you
all right i have it there's a canteus here if anyone wants it this canteus good i love canteus We actually have a sick army.
Yeah.
Yeah, our stuff is pretty good.
I don't like the LMGs.
I don't think they're very good.
You know, like, like, if SureFour was here, like, I think we'd just be, like, wiping the lobby and lessen.
Yeah, I don't think it would have been really fair.
By the way, guys, SureFour was...
originally um could have came over too oh he was gonna play it didn't you say tell us that they uh just he didn't want to fly so they didn't come oh true true yeah
all right yeah i mean they would probably put him on a different team right i don't think so i think he'd be on our team i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure yeah because then like like it just be like vibing maybe i'll try this gun should i follow
where do we oh wait i see there's people here there's people here there's people in front of me
oh there's oh there's oh there's sniper i got sniped i got his shot i got his shot i got his shot it was one hit it was one hit it was actually one hit oh my god he hit shot me other guns the Katius is the best gun you don't understand oh get up and fight us don't be up don't be up okay nice nice I need a heal I'm like not okay right now over here in front of me
100.
I got him, I got him.
What?
What the hell did you guys land?
I don't know, but that messed me up.
Yay!
Yeah, if you have blue armor, it's not for one shot.
Yeah, I got headshot instantly.
That's scariest.
I need that purple armor.
Does anyone have purple armor?
No.
Wait, player two, can I have purple armor?
armor now he's getting crazy like now we're getting there too can i please have purple armor on the support i need to be alive isn't player three your friends why don't you ask your friend because i want to i want to build a relationship with player two oh so you're gonna build a relationship by taking his on no i no i'm asking them nicely if i could have their uh their purple armor so that as a team player the support can have like better armor also i'm taking that car because we need more than one car yeah there's the the fast one with the booster right here we so now i'm armored up where are we going yeah you can't i'm gonna drive on this bridge but i can't drive there
Oh, wait, you did it.
Oh, wait, what?
It looked like you missed earlier.
It did start falling, Anna.
Yeah, I literally saw you falling.
There's, like, barely a bridge here.
I mean, it's broken.
Wait, do we not want to get the upgrade from that?
No, we can't from that one.
You see how it's not active on the map?
Okay, we're not on the map.
I just noticed that this zone is closing.
Wee.
We just got dead center, maybe.
Can't you find a One of those things Leveling up Oh Is there a car here?
There's people here Okay Give me a sec I'm having trouble Why else is this car dead?
Yeah yeah I'm having trouble Right now Oh hey
Can I Can I try to drive him over Like He's in a car You can drive him over I thought I could ram him I don't know Oh sorry He just rammed that tree Don't worry, guys.
I'm heading over.
Wait.
He's got a shield.
You're not doing it.
You're just carrying him.
You gotta break the shield first.
Hello.
I'll take him over to us.
Is he still alive?
You want to do a finisher?
We could have done a finisher on...
I was trying to take him over to you so you can do a finisher on him.
So it's now it's just playing a baseball.
Yes.
That's your friend.
It's called constructive criticism.
Reloading.
Watch out.
Stop running low.
You're a clinker.
Why am I?
Why didn't you get your car?
I don't know why you... Get back into your car!
It's kind of messed up.
What happened to your other car?
There's another car.
There's another car right there.
I'm taking you guys to this car.
Get your own car.
She just doesn't.
You just.
Okay.
You just don't want us in front of her.
Yeah.
Get your own car.
You can't free load off of my car.
You and player D are going to go this way.
You're not breaking your car, right?
No, you're not.
You're barely doing anything.
You did like one damage to my car.
Maybe learn to drive better.
I'm going to jump.
I'm literally in chat.
Me and player two are hanging out.
Our player two?
He's just messing around.
Wee.
I mean, there's still 10 squads alive.
Oh, wait.
There's a fight in front of us.
I saw gunshots right here.
Oh, yeah.
Is that a human being over there?
Oh, that's a bush.
I saw.
Behind us?
These guys are speaking behind us.
Wait, behind us?
Oh.
Yeah.
Point.
Oh, yeah.
Big fight.
Okay, I'm gonna go over here.
Oh, they're like drive-bying.
It's drive-by?
Drive-by.
Wait, where are you guys shooting at?
Come on?
Can I get a heal?
The road, the road, right?
Are you running them over?
You think you're so hot.
Hey,
if it works, it works.
Why put more effort in shooting than what I could just drive them over?
There's a car.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, wait, I'm gonna...
Don't worry.
We got you.
No!
don't worry i got you okay i'll go rest player two i'll go rest player two i'm sorry oh there's a guy there's a guy i'm dying i'm dying too i'm dying too i'm getting in the car hold on hold on hold on heal up i did i did we play defense here but here in the car they're gonna run us over we're gonna run front of me too i'm trying to rest i'm trying to rest i'm trying to rest i'm I'm rushing,
I'm rising.
Oh my god, I think everybody else is starting to run people over.
Okay, I'm here.
Where's the guy?
Where are they?
One guy's on me?
You get him?
Wait, do you finish it?
Do you finish it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it did.
And then they have self-rise.
Just making sure I'm in peak condition.
Oh wait, no.
Okay.
Hold it, hold it, hold it.
All right.
There was some guy shooting.
These guys still not.
There's some guy.
Here, here.
There's a two team.
Do you see me?
This guy is one team.
This is another team.
This is another team on me.
There's another team on me.
There's Sam.
I just scan that guy and I don't know where.
There's another guy right here.
He's behind that rock and then there's a guy behind the tree.
Look on the road on the left.
Look on the road.
Yeah, yeah, I'm looking at this.
Oh, nice.
This is the other guy.
What then?
God, he's dead.
He's dead.
I don't know where his teammates are though.
I don't know, but let me execute.
Let me execute.
There's this guy.
Execute this guy.
Oh, wait.
They're both dead.
Oh, yeah.
Execute this guy.
Right here.
Yeah, but they're not on the same team.
This they are.
No, no, no.
This guy has three teammates on.
Oh, wait.
Over here, over here, in the house, in the house.
Oh yeah, car house.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get over here!
I'm gonna execute again.
Okay.
Look at that map.
Oh, there's the res, it's the res.
And there's another guy over here, the res.
Okay, you see them have one here, one here?
Yeah.
Nice player's three.
I'm getting Ubered.
Give me, I'm gonna loot this real quick before I...
I have to go jive.
All right.
Yay.
Wait, take me to this car.
Take me to this car.
I want that car.
We gotta get three-quarter car.
I can move for now or what?
No, so I can...
So we can all run over somebody.
All right, let's go.
Oh, look.
I was getting...
Camped.
What the hell?
Here, from where I'm handing over, I'm healing.
Channeling source energy.
Nice, you.
But luckily it's on the left of the...
Oh, and the hill?
Running that way somewhere.
Like more left.
Yeah?
Down here?
Look where player three is.
Yeah?
I was just left.
No one took me out.
Where's player three?
Where?
Oh, he killed somebody.
Look at him go.
He just thrown him over.
I'm so proud of you.
Look, see?
All right, here you go.
All right, where do we go?
All right.
Center zone.
I'm gonna pick this.
I'll grab us another car.
I think they're...
Ow.
Can you guys stop that?
What do you mean?
I have the right of way!
I have the right of way.
They were the ones that ran me.
It's a battle royale game.
There's no right of way.
Okay.
Get that car.
And then we'll all have four cars.
We're gonna do a drive-by.
Go pop, Alright, let's go.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Turn the hoop off.
Yeah.
Somebody's gonna get on the news.
Oh my god.
One more joke with us and we lose this one more.
What about this air job?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, across.
Across, across.
Where is he?
Oh, he's over there.
killed one maybe this killed one for sure oh they're getting in the car he's in the car he's gonna res yeah they're not in the car anymore we don't finish it it's over here he's over there he's over there he's over there he's over there he dropped down he crawled down he's over here oh yes teammate I'm doing the dokey where's the teammate oh my god I sent her flying oh they're full dead Yeah,
they're full of dead.
Nice.
Let's go.
That's actually the strongest thing in the game.
Yeah, exactly.
That's why I said it was different cars.
That's why I learned in the tournament.
After getting run over multiple times at the tournament, I learned.
I know what's the strongest.
You remember when we were out of tree and we just got around the forest?
Yeah, multiple times we died in the tournament from cars.
Yep.
This is what I learned.
Now, oh, there's another car over there.
There's a guy driving over there.
Oh, they're doing it.
They're doing it.
You see how the color changed the blue?
No.
Oh, I see it.
I didn't see it.
Car is meta.
No enemies.
No, no enemies.
Are you sure?
I think you...
Maybe I didn't reach the right side.
Because I think they're due.
I don't know.
Or maybe they did it.
I think maybe they finished it.
Yeah, there's no...
No, I saw a car driving away earlier.
That's the thing.
There's a Tempest LMG here.
Take it.
Player three is very far away.
I'm gonna need to find a new car soon.
I need a new car.
I'm running out of...
There's a new car right here.
Where?
Up here?
Oh.
Nah, we'll find another car.
Okay, this guy's literally driving on me.
Let's go right side.
It's probably gonna end.
Okay.
let's see I'm heading over there's a new car down here oh nice yeah I'll grab that car yeah I need that car I'm gonna use up all the gas too and he took your car oh my god I used the majority of my gas for that there's a new car here wait wait okay I'll take that then I think there's I don't want the other side of the bridge wait actually I want this I want the the space car yeah this is the this
I think they're doing this one on the right.
Yeah, it's not blue anymore.
Oh, there's a gold package, too.
I'm pretty sure they'll head over there, right?
There, Jesus, shit.
Oh, that's good.
Yeah, they're doing it.
It's red now.
Oh, that means it's supposed to be.
Do I...
Do I need anything?
Oh, my God!
Okay.
Um, um, that's not good.
That's not.
So maybe we dome here and we res?
Um, I don't think.
I'm resing.
Come to us.
I am.
I'm here.
Can you heal him?
Yeah, I'm healing him.
They're throwing Stavarazas.
I just don't know from where.
I don't know.
They haven't moved from their spot on.
Okay.
They're still up there.
He's gonna use the...
He's gonna use the ult, you know, the bombardment.
Yeah, she did.
These guys are...
These guys know how to play.
I mean, I'm worried about getting shot in the back though, that's the thing.
Wait.
We are getting shot in the back.
From very far.
They're really far away though, right?
Yeah, but it's still not ideal, you know?
I might have just rotate.
I would just rotate, honestly.
But I'm cooking them.
Yeah, but we can wait.
Now I got cracked in my back.
Okay, we actually got to go.
Yeah, yeah, that's what I'm seeing.
Bye Player 3.
Yeah, there's another team shooting at us.
There's another.
There's another team.
I like how you guys left me.
I'm sorry.
There's another.
No, there's another card.
There's another card behind you.
Yeah, I got it.
Okay.
Where do we go?
Let's go north.
Where's north?
Oh, this way, okay.
You get this hill up north.
Here, this one?
Yeah, this big one.
Five, there's three.
Just chill on this hill and they're gonna fight each other.
Hello.
We're gonna win and sadly we can't get...
Wait, do you have the orb?
Oh, this is a new team running at them, right?
Is there?
I mean, a card just pulled up.
that's good then we get distracted oh shit we got the we got that I mean oh I got him 76 nice I don't know how far I shot that from are they in his own yeah they're getting shot at right now by the way
I want 10 on one what the fuck someone they shot me i'm just gonna heal real quick try for real i think they're gonna fight each other they are fighting they are shooting yeah they are fighting let the right team push the left team they just shoot at the left and oh knock one knock one nice nice can we break his shield and finish him and try i don't know we can pick this team up though
own and it's closing in 40 seconds i don't think we can get this guy wait wait wait behind behind us behind us where i don't know i don't know i'm right there i'm missing i'm missing i can't i can't commit to it i can't commit to it the rabbit loss i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead very nice i can't it's up to you it's up to you i'm fully dead
I streamed.
It would be kind of crazy if we won four now.
A little crazy.
Oh, there was another team pushing us in front of us too.
Yeah, no, we were...
Destroyed the last three teams that are gonna fight.
Yeah, yeah, no, there's still three, four teams left, but there was another team that pushed us too, so we were not gonna live anyway.
Guys, I think...
I think... I think this was planned.
I think this was planned.
I had a plan.
feeling we're gonna get pushed.
There was no way we were saved.
75% win rate is good enough.
100% win rate would be crazy.
There was, I know there was no way we win that.
Those guys on the, what was it?
The, the, the, the enhancer thing were actually pretty good.
Yeah.
It was impossible to push them down.
This person's pushing with no HP.
I don't, maybe they ran out of his.
That was insane.
That was the team that won the fight after we got third-party?
That was the team that killed us.
Yeah.
No, they got third-party after.
Like, another team ran at them after.
After they killed us.
So this is a duo.
One turn secure.
Okay, okay.
Oh, no.
This is the...
This is last.
Yeah.
Last the team.
Oh, yeah, Otto.
Oh, what?
Goodbye, Otto.
Goodbye.
I think that look hard to watch.
this one.
The day?
Doki, we finally reached a point where you were uncarriable.
Okay, that was not my fault.
That was not my fault there.
I did so much for you.
I even healed you.
What did you say?
What happened this time?
Yeah, what happened?
Doki finally reached the level where she was uncarriable.
Wow!
I was literally second frag around behind you.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean, also, just wouldn't be fair if we won every game.
So RPR through.
RPR through.
Yeah, we won three out of four.
I think that's good enough.
Let other people win one.
You know, we're fair play, fair play.
He just didn't want to win a fourth game.
I'll enjoy breaking it down.
You were actually too, too heavy this round.
Wait, okay.
Player two, accept my friend request.
Okay.
Player two does not like you.
No, you don't know that.
You don't know that.
He'll eventually...
my friend oh no wait i had no we did yeah we are friends i literally checked to make sure you made sure we're friends yeah i made sure that we are at it
see player two friend accept my friend request
it's all i want wait why did you kick me i just kicked you i just kicked you that's messed up Was that the last game?
Oh, GG's!
GG's games come!
Everybody there, GG's.
We purposely lost so we could give other people a chance to win, right RPA?
You managed to flame like...
I did not flame anyone!
I did not flame anyone.
It was only player two.
Because...
Should I throw it in the sun?
It was...
Removing ignorance and showing us the way forward.
I just got a goodie bag if you want to watch, by the way.
Wait, a goodie bag.
Wait, can you give me a goodie bag, too?
Can I have one?
Can I give you one?
No, can I have a goodie bag, too?
I'm pretty sure if you asked, Dez, can I...
Well, am I still broadcast?
Dez, can I have a goodie bag?
You're not broadcast.
But basically, what you're going to do is you get a mouse pad.
The one that I'm using right now.
You get a...
Wait, I'm not broadcast anymore?
A little cheering thing?
No, you're not on broadcast.
The world doesn't revolve around you, bro.
Well, I could just be like, at this can i also have a goodie bag if i was still broadcast this is also a bag if i saw a bag right here you get a shirt i think you get a hoodie through and then you can actually bait your bag okay which is like oh cool i can't wait to get my hoodie bag as well guys oh take a picture okay have anything better to click on one second bear okay wait he just bribed me for a picture okay guys well
that's fun though i had a lot of fun i hope everybody at gamescon had a lot of fun but my broadcast i can't really say that i can't really ask them if if they did you guys have fun too but it was really i had a i had a lot of fun time playing um with the people at gamescom and we guys had fun watching huge thank you and shout again to fake trigger for this sponsor you guys the stream and the game.
Please feel free to click on the link.
Check out the game yourself.
Um, it helps out a lot for the stream and for the sponsor.
Yeah!
Have a lot of fun.
I hope you guys had fun watching.
Um, I figured out the settings too, very early on.
I had to take a picture of the cosplayers.
Some things you can do because you're at home.
I mean, they could turn my broadcast back on and I could take a picture of them.
They could do that.
It makes me wonder.
Just how are these people?
Choice.
Oh, the character?
I actually didn't play her.
I played this character.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
What?
What's going on?
The cosplayer came up to me and said, nice choice for playing her character, but I was playing the other character, but this was just the default one on screen.
Oh!
No!
That's so hard!
Oh, you got a booboo?
Yeah, I got a booboo.
Oh, that's cute.
If our world is like a pale blue dot in the dark...
GGs.
GGs are everywhere.
Yeah, I'm going to go head to bed, but GGs...
Oh, we have fun at Gamescom.
Yeah, I'm going to explore Gamescom and...
Yeah, alright.
Bye-bye.
Peace, peace.
Alright, guys.
Like I said, shout out again and thank you to fate trigger for the sponsor i hope everyone had fun watching i hope everyone at gamescon had fun playing and watching with us too um as always everybody i'm gonna head to bed take a little nap before my next stream but as always everybody stay hydrated watch the check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye